episode is brought to you by this skin
guys get your information every morning
from the skin newsletter for the skin
helps me stay in the know on topics like
all topics because I'm bad at being in
the know but this game is basically a
newsletter delivered to your email for
free every morning you get politics
sports entertainment and heaps more
right now you can go to the skin calm
that's the sk IMM calm / and julian
enter your email click subscribe that's
it that's that's all you have to do so
just go subscribe to the skin they'll
send you an newsletter every morning of
what's happening in the world to help
you be educated and have conversations
with your co-workers that you hate just
kidding check it out this game right now
also when you enter using our URL you
can be entered for a chance to win a
$250 Visa gift card also sponsored by
thredUP hey guys you want to know a
secret way to get 90% off ninety percent
of top name brand name and designer
clothing like Lululemon Gap j.crew
Express all the good stuff
all the good stuff isn't a brand it's
just me saying there's more and there's
ma weight right now in addition to the
discounts they already have you go to
thread up and you get an extra 40
percent of your first order with our URL
so go to thread thr Edie you pee comm /
Jenna Julian and you use promo code
Jenna Dewan get 40% off your first order
on top of all the discounts they have
tons of brand names tons of brand name
secondhand clothing really nice they
make sure everything's perfect and you
will be happy with what you want so
thank you to our sponsors Thank You
sponsors it's lit oh my god we're just
gonna eat that penny I've been eating it
freely boy why oh my god you're one of
those people that's true your pants oh
babe we have the break-up we're gonna
have to break another single Julie I
hate when people would do that when they
would ask you don't I can't
can I borrow a pen and you give it to
them and then they chew on it and I'm
like [ __ ] you you want other people's
pens babe okay don't group me into those
monsters please why are you trying on my
because it's a tick and I like chewing
on pen I don't think it's a tick I think
no it's absolutely not a tick okay it's
it's just a habit
okay sorry that I'm not perfect there
good gun
you're not even we broke up so it's fine
no I will be doing on it sporadically
throughout the podcast so if you get
away from you maybe just leave me alone
about it oh maybe you leave me alone on
it fine
so no I have a disclaimer - what I
wanted okay I want to say I know
frequently my family and friends will
watch the podcasts to be supportive and
amazing
I'd like to deter any of you if you're
watching right now - maybe just click
away and go to the next episode or a
previous episode but just don't watch
this episode yeah especially parents
don't watch mom or dad okay I'm gonna
say I feel like your dad would
understand this game your mom maybe not
so much my mom wouldn't understand my
dad would understand but still wouldn't
like it he'd be like it neither of my
parents I don't think would particularly
like this actually Deb you probably
fully understands it um so we wanted to
play a game because this was inspired by
a tweet that I saw which was really I
forgot who tweeted it which I feel
really bad shouts out to the person we'd
like to give credit where credit is due
but I genuinely forgot it and didn't
favorite it so I can't find it
but it was like comments in 2015 like oh
my god I love you lol comments in 2016
like [ __ ] me daddy
and then comments 2017 on the internet
run over my body with your car and lick
my [ __ ]
yeah so I started thinking of a way that
we could make a game and make a series
of 2017 comments so this actually
started out we did have a third cup that
was just filled with like daddy father
queen mommy like that kind of thing
mounds yeah and we decided it didn't it
doesn't even really need it like in
order to make the
formula to make a 20-17 comment is just
the first part you know and the second
part
that's Julian's mom calling him right
now she knows yeah she knows so
basically this is the 2017 comment
generator yeah okay so the formula is
like anything that's sexual and/or
violent and/or makes no sense and or
just asking something to be done to that
person violence right exactly
we basically constructed two different
cups full of the beginning half and then
the and and second half yeah of what's
of what makes up the 2017 cons so
basically what we're gonna do is we
reach gonna pull I mean some of them
aren't gonna work so how am I gonna be
funny
it'll make a 20-17 comment and I'll make
a 20-17 comment and then we'll decide on
the winner all right so I'm gonna take
one of each and you take one of each
real make some up to each other okay the
number ones have never won right not
nothing to see you know okay it's very
you a first all right
paint me like one of your french girls
and hold me hostage until I develop
Stockholm Syndrome
that's the 2017 comment like someone
would tweet that at you yeah yeah what's
yours penetrate me with both arms can
ambush me with a squirt gun full of wet
paint paint me like one of your french
girls and hold the hostage until they
develop Stockholm hold me hostage until
I develop right which one wins I kind of
like yours yeah mine's pretty dope I
mean the squirt gun full of lead paint
it's pretty great pretty good what's the
first party years again penetrate me
with both arms yeah mine wins right you
win
no no no plans so 2017 comment paint me
like one of your french girls
alright you pull the next one what are
you doing I just my mom call me twice as
well make sure everything's chill right
I understand
sort of I'm kidding I did alright
Wow all I gotta say
Wow okay my 20-17 comment is chokeslam
me through a door and superglue my ass
shut what do you annihilate me with your
tesla and threatened me with biochemical
warfare until I surrender god here's one
here's one chokeslam me through a door
is superglue my ass shut that's a great
[ __ ] cop superglue my ass shot yeah
like just the cheeks you know oh well
you do the whole and the cheeks and you
squeeze them together until it dries you
have to hold the butt closed forever no
like how long do have to physical just
maybe a minute or so it's a little
hardens yet no yeah but that's really
after you chokeslam me through the door
well that knocks them out we're blaming
this on you but these came from our
brain and [ __ ] like let's be honest but
that's like really really though this is
like should the people comment well yeah
is that spider on this cup what is that
it's just like lint it's not even
looking why'd you bring it towards me
like that well it'll scare you why did
you put those back what are you doing oh
[ __ ] I don't know but those are that say
are you even here sorry I apologize
there was a little bit of a mix-up with
this but or no there was it happy that
it didn't need to happen are you first
all right
20:17 comment off boy all right so dark
are you a first freshly grind pepper
into my eyes and throw me like a grenade
I like that okay mine is darker homie
like a grenade
like way to dietary incinerate my entire
lower half and skull-fuck my corpse okay
so but at least that makes sense that
because your lower it is no no way
mine's too dark freshly grind pepper
into my eyes and throw me like a grenade
into the Grand Canyon yeah I'll take the
the winner all right keep it over there
yeah so we can keep count all right so
just keep your winning cards right yeah
losing cards go over there all right and
don't want you losers all right what do
you got what do you got straddle me like
a horse and FaceTime me while you rob a
bank suspend me in a 10-foot cage and do
a wheelie over my spied on your Vespa I
like the second part but the temper cage
makes it impossible to do a wheelie on
top of them well you never know maybe
they're at the circus it's a little
far-fetched I like yeah you definitely
win that just imagine a guy on a horse
read it again
straddle straddle me like a horse and
faced on me while you rob a bank
[Laughter]
tweet it Shane Dawson yeah all right
this is basically an entire podcast
dedicated to shame it really is rip my
wig off and shake my [ __ ] with your
jawline [ __ ]
finger me like you're manually rewinding
a VHS tape and someone like a VHS you
like you're manually rewinding of VHS
tape I like to call me from prison that
is incredibly I'm pretty proud of that
card we often shake my [ __ ] with you
jaw lines okay but what if we combine oh
why don't we both think that it could be
better served if I combine like my a
with your B there we go
finger me like you're manually rewinding
a VHS tape and shake my [ __ ] with your
jaw line ah good you guys are all
welcome to steal these by the way yeah
you guys can have these credit us please
no seriously we don't want our names
attached to this does podcast okay god
man all right I have give me a dead leg
and gently slide you so violently you
have to really punch someone's leg to
give them dead leg distract from the
galaxy sliding yeah so it doesn't hurt
when it goes up your back yeah I would
see note seven gently kickflip over my
dead body and smuggle me right sorry
and smuggle me through customs like a
balloon of heroin I think yours may yeah
I like the vein
give me a dead like and gently slide
your Galaxy Note seven I like I like the
fact that it's a Galaxy Note seven
because it's probably the most dangerous
phone to slide up something it's gonna
catch on fire in that person's but
that's that dead leg is is a precursor
to what's gonna happen to you your dead
leg Wow
all right
what is wrong with 2017
Wow okay what mine is cover my vagina
and ant traps and drag me through a
field of landmines tie me up with your
macbook charger and DIY LASIK me LASIK
eye surgery yours wins dr wines not that
good guys what how long until the DIY
scene on YouTube just turns completely
rogue I don't know and they start DIY
and the most dangerous things I honestly
thought that the thousand degree knife
challenge was one of the most dangerous
like challenges I usually like holding
for 10 torches at once lighting their
kitchen on fire well I feel like a
blowtorch is a little more controlled
like you you know what's gonna happen
you know it's gonna melt or catch on
fire sort of because you can direct it
but like a thousand degree knife seemed
really [ __ ] dangerous because like
challenges on YouTube are like oh
there's a challenge going around
everyone can do it like the feast swap
challenge whatever yeah the kids are
doing the thousand degree knife thing
but I was wild I feel like that was sort
of when the DIY challenge that might
have been the nail in the coffin for
challenges yeah maybe
no I mean it was just that's the thing
like it didn't it wasn't a challenge it
started out as like just a fake render
whatever cars some water like red hot
nickel ball that's all that channel does
yeah but that's way og like that was
that that transcends and predates this
knife trend man the knife trend came out
because that guy mr. gear or whatever
was doing it and everyone started
watching it was just so satisfying but
he's like a hydraulic press channel like
not everyone can go on by how a
hydraulic press but everyone can go out
and buy a knife and let them blow it no
it's just one of those things like
YouTube is just super [ __ ] weird
weird fun regular
really play like are you gonna do that
it was like how about [ __ ] though you
don't want to light my house on fire
I like Ethan MELAS yes funny Lauren I
have fill my [ __ ] with cake batter and
hold me hostage
and a kids are us oh my gosh Jam me and
a panini press and slowly die on me
oh my god which one's better I like the
second I like hold me hostage in two
kids are us yeah that one's good you win
what was the first five years again
Jimmy and a panini press and slowly die
on me that's so [ __ ] I'm winning oh no
guys if you're this far into the podcast
and you still don't really understand
what's happening I don't really blame
you but it's it's like it's almost like
the one-upping of like when fans are
people in the internet or commenting or
meeting at their favorite people they
want to like draw that shock value of
like I love you this much that it's so
shiny so shocking that I want you to run
over my body and like kill me right like
and it just I think it's a very funny if
you look at it funny perspective it's a
very funny trend it's like it's
hilarious it is [ __ ] fun it's funny
it is it's funny because it's like I
think it's funny all right you go first
this end comment off don't come on
where's it's a pound my gaping [ __ ]
and snot rocket into my butt actually
works together alright - hit me with a
steaming hot wok and trample my taint
wok imagine like you go to the kitchen
you light the stove and you turn on the
wok until it starts steaming and you
just take just 13 okay I have a quest
basically what position does the person
have to be like handstand position you
just know like maybe laying on your back
with your legs like over your head so
your butts like in the air yeah you just
rant on the date yeah just the team but
what have you actually hit like the
balls well that's on you that's your
fault
it takes a tiny little target it is that
was you know so let oh no that was a
literation
yeah I don't even know if that counts is
trampling though because that's only
like one point of pressure I feel like
tramplings like multiple points of
pressure trampling is is like multiple
not points of pressure but multiple
sources of it like different people are
different and feet like and feet there
needs to be like an army of feet going
after one little taint or it could be
like this is Bigfoot who's getting his
taint and all these normal sense humans
feet fit perfectly oh my gosh
yours wins it yours wins read it again
pound my gaping [ __ ] it's not rocket
into my butt yeah that wins I references
but twice which I think it shows
dedication to the but it does it's a
good job mm-hmm good dedicated joke yeah
alright it's no rabid bit want me to
read mine first if you want Bibby also
guys on the comment section on this
video I expect nothing less than this
just all these comments yeah
like comments like well we know that you
guys are good at them because those of
you that follow us like on Twitch like
the we stream like which is where really
my god yeah we stream on Twitch every
week on Mondays twitch.tv slash Jenna
Julian and the ding fam who shows up at
the twitch chats like they take they
take some joke that happens in the video
game like like the clip thing played
life is strange there's a million jokes
like a million Joe they make these jokes
so shocking and so if you like visit the
comments for like a second you're not
used to being there you're like what the
[ __ ] is happening but it's amazing it's
really alright run me over with your
motorcycle and blow me like a vuvuzela
we had one here so great
what's your I got one at a monster truck
gym I went to a monster truck like rally
and they were giving them out that I've
ever been to a monster truck show but I
have been to multiple demolition derbies
I've never been to a demolition oh my
god they're so [ __ ] incredible
we should go yeah we should find one I
don't know if there are any here didn't
go to like I'm just like straight hick
[ __ ] upstate New York that's what I used
to do let's do it in case you didn't
know I'm kind of way trash it's kind of
my job I am what I am your job can't
help it yeah okay maybe you can power
clean my soft penis and text and drive
over me into a McDonald's Drive power
clean me with your soft penis alright
Julian that wins okay that [ __ ] wins
power clean me with your soft penis that
was incredible
I'm pretty proud of that one what text
and drive over me oh my god what vomit
into my mouth and cut off my skin to use
it as a kite oh my god up alright mine
is hit me in the shin with your scooter
and spit acid on my face hit me in the
shin with your scooter yeah that is that
wins that's pretty great yeah I don't
know that hurts so bad logistically
about spitting acid mm-hmm if you're a
human you know normal humans can't how
about maybe their reptilian probably
alien I think that makes no sense yeah
it's interesting maybe you should think
of the perspective of these comments as
a reptile is writing them and then it
will all make more sense be logistically
more impossible
all right you okay Oh God
what did you write this one I can't even
this is so [ __ ]
what barricade me inside your safe room
and come in my nose while I sneeze you
vote that one I wrote barricade me
inside your safe room my nose I sneeze I
recall yes you did I'd like to I'd like
to first of all they're all in your
handwriting no they're not I don't even
have a pen
all right mine is death drop your ass
onto my face and use my body as chains
for your tires okay
death drop my ass drop your ass if you
guys don't know what death dropping is
it's a dance move where you just all of
a sudden you're like this week and you
fall flat on your back it's from that's
from a movement called voguing it's
incredible and I read it like YouTube
videos to people death drop don't try it
though especially if you have weak knees
or bad knees into the dog bed when they
yeah it was pretty good though yeah you
were like low to the ground rocking back
and forth it didn't finally just went
back it could have been that it could
have been like man death drops into
fireplace and catches a house on fire
that's very true and you guys would have
read about it on the skin the next day
because it would've been a top news
story that you wouldn't because you're
connected to what's going on via the
skin newsletter in your email inbox
oh my god guys the skin serves news
right when you need it fast every single
morning and it's with style and no BS
it's delivered in one email in your
inbox and it's free it's not a free
trial it's free you subscribe and you
get the newsletter every day it makes it
easier for you to be smarter with the
latest on world news politics sports
entertainment even if you you know get
your information on Twitter there's a
lot that you're missing that can fall
through the cracks and skim will fill
those cracks in for you and it's really
nice it is really great
um in like I said like you know if you
go to a job with other people and
there's small talk and you know
water-cooler talk it's it's nice to have
a few facts in your pocket ready to just
like sling it [ __ ] Susan from
accounting it was just oh my god stop
dropping all these anyway right now you
can go to the skin that's the sk IMM
comm slash Jenna Julianne into your
email click Subscribe it's that simple
that's that's all we want you to do just
subscribe it doesn't cost any money 4
million people right now are waking up
with this game every morning even Oprah
guys that's that's actually the whole
sales pitch Oprah does it so please do
it now right now if you sign up at this
game back on San Julian you have the
chance to win a $250 Visa gift card
that's the skin with two M's SK IMM calm
/ Jenna Julian thank you this skin and
now guys to your stylish needs the
thread up is our next sponsors actually
just thread up the thread up makes it so
you can get up to 90% off name brands
and designer clothing like I said uh
Banana Republic and Taylor anthropology
all these different stores that cost a
lot of money when you when you buy
clothes from them thread up it makes it
easy for you to shop on trend and with
like new fashion clothing really great
shape clothing and you can get it for a
fantastic discount right now you will
also get a 40% off your first order on
top of the discounts that they already
have on their site thread up triple
inspects each item by hand triple which
is really good quality control to ensure
that all the clothes are like new and
lots even have the tags still attached
to the garment once you find a great
deal you order it and your items will
arrive folded with care and thread UPS
signature polka dot box it's a really
nice packaging if you haven't seen it
but right now just go to thread up
that's thre DUP comm slash annejulien
you enter promo code Jenna Julian and
you get an extra 40 percent off your
first order thread up check it out guys
and you know if you check it out you
find something tweet us a picture of
your new garment man I want to see that
thread up has so many options for you if
you look in a shop on a budget and
get nice clothing so thank you thread up
now my mama is a purse from thredUP
check it out sure it's pretty red one
yeah oh that is from Paris yeah pretty
sure it's like BCBG or something and I
was like mom did you get a new purse
like you guys know the Debbie Machine
like she's not very fancy like she
probably has one purse at a time you
know like just I never actually thought
of that so that's what you said she's
like I got it from the set up so I was
like damn mom listen on first the pop of
color it threat alright let's let's keep
it moving who's winning three four five
six
oh [ __ ] we're gonna end up with 1500
[ __ ] are you going first or me oh you
were first hurl me off the side of a
Disney Cruise and litter my throat with
your toenail clippings
Julianne why'd you write all these gross
one litter my throat that is so nasty
including its gnats look that's love
it's so nasty
mine is stomp on my pelvic bone and make
me eat your iPhone so you can use me as
Apple pay cash or credit
Apple pay so would the person's stomach
have to like be near the register all
this is great because then it would just
be stuck in there like a lodged in it or
you just lodged in their throat they put
their head on them on the reader perfect
they're probably dead but to go oh god
zongman yes definitely
wait okay so we have yeah all right
there you got strangle me with a giant
dildo and ground and pound me
unconscious
mine is spinning back elbow me in the
elbow and gag me like a car - I like all
the - MMA themed ones popped up yeah
right back elbow me and the elbow and
gag me like a Kardashian just spinning
back ah boys have you ever watched John
Jones fajitas demonstrations like yeah
give us a demonstration let's go all
right I need to do I need to do it give
me a target it's a swimming bag of is if
I spin and I but like as hard as you can
yeah so like your funny bone definitely
gets to both funny bones
yeah like no one's getting out of there
alive like that's that's a mutually
destructive [ __ ] attack elbows I
imagine we get really cut because your
elbows so sharp we don't like that
stabbing knives your elbows cut open and
so is mine and then you get blood from
the elbows on to the person's face and
then gag me like a Kardashian then you
run me over with your ATV God dragged me
through barbed wire go who want me take
me wakeboarding on shards of glass
instead of water deliberately hide my
passport
you cut me in line to get a MetroCard oh
my god all right so we have two more you
know one more leap you're winning are
you not Oh waiting no I have this one no
it's tied seven to seven yeah so this is
the this is my dog beans are here what
does a bean mean
you were first [ __ ] me in the belly
button and pummel me with your squash
there's a squash racket that one's
pretty good either it's a big belly
button or tiny little penis or you do
make it work okay put boiling hot Orbeez
on my nipples and visit me in jail fully
dressed as spider-man me with your
squash racquet visit me in jail fully
dressed as my imaginary go into
visitation in jail really did win trying
to seriously visit someone but their
head-to-toe spider-man he really did win
read it again put boiling hot Orbeez on
my nipples dress spider-man and Jeff all
right now we should make before we end
we should make like MVP ones we should
hand make them alright well they take
our favorite one takes them from your
winning pie yeah of course
Marvel said it blew my ass shut that
one's pretty good hit me in the shin
with your scooter yeah hold me hostage
and the kids are us ok spinning back
elbow me in the elbow okay this one's
pretty good finger me like you're
manually rewinding a VHS tape and Tommy
like a grenade and then a grandkid
like I want to see these comments
popping up on other people's videos
please they're pretty great please
speech spinning back elbow me in the
elbow and superglue my ass shut no it's
being back homie in the elbow and then
that one and DIY LASIK DIY LASIK someone
mode you get a laser uh-huh you can buy
them off certain website go on the dark
web
yeah I'm just kidding you ladies go on
and then have someone lay in a bed in
your house open their eyes wrap their
eyes open and just shoot the lasers
their eyes and like hope that something
happens already bleeding oh my god is
the whole thing a lot more you're
distracted you're not worried about the
laser because your elbows cut gashed
wide open you're sick
DIY LASIK what's another MVP sooner
therapy so gently Jen
gently slide your Galaxy Note seven of
math this is that an and okay so that's
number two you need a number one power
clean my soft penis and gently slide
your penis not only has to be soft but
it has to be pretty pretty flexible like
yeah like in that garbage movie the
Fantastic Four or the guy who can bend
and around like Robert like his dick
imagine that that's the kind of dick
I've never thought about his dick I
guess you never thought about his dick
no why I use that with Stretch Armstrong
too and I was a kid too because they I
don't know just what you dick just I
miss our new tumbler just stretchy dick
things
well what would even be on their
stretchy dick things like Stretch
Armstrong fan fiction and the guy from
Fantastic Four fan fiction and that's it
that's literally it and and experiments
trials what does that mean I'm trying to
stretch my dick you know not like safely
what do you mean we're gonna take tiny
doses of rubber each day as vitamins and
then see if I can I don't think that
would gain elasticity I don't think that
would work
I don't think you know what you're
talking about driver dick I don't think
you'll be as stretchy as my it so big it
would oh please don't pitch it no oh my
god Julian no power my skin it's such
like a an impossible movement to do
anything to anyone's body unless your
power clean your whole body it's either
a whole body or none of it mm-hmm well
next week on the Gingin podcasts we're
gonna be doing some more of these
hard-hitting topics really hide my
passport and hold me hostage inside of
the kids R Us yeah well for right now if
you guys could do us the favor of
hitting us with some of these style
comments right now in the comment
section and we will go through and
potentially pin one and maybe love a
couple
have you noticed you can love comments
though no you can even love comments on
YouTube open and it says the person and
you only the person who made that video
can love it like not everyone can like
it gives like the seal of approval I saw
so you might love some of your comments
if you make them all [ __ ] up and weird
like these yeah well I mean what I
appreciate as we were like writing these
the the more specific and like
ridiculous they are the better yeah
they're specific and like really really
really specific like this I feel like
the gist of Internet comments in 2017
are a fan comments are like either
outrageously violent or outrageously
sexual yes and they're insane they're so
uncomfortable but you know like the most
well mannered nice little 14 year old
[ __ ] wrote that I know and that's the
funniest part like these adorable little
like young [ __ ] people over the
Internet are coming up with the darkest
most [ __ ] up [ __ ] that you could have
ever [ __ ] the Internet man that's
what I like
praise Millennials to no end and like
kids that are teenagers right now
because they're they're exposed to
everything and they [ __ ] get it and
it's honestly it's just kind of like
another
humor that's been joins and like you
look at like um I don't know the shock
factor of that sort of comedy has made
appearances and all sorts of you know
moments in comedy history like a lot of
comedy history is made up of shock value
you know commentary and this is sort of
like the new kind of version it's pretty
good it's pretty good it's really funny
I love you Internet I love you too
Internet I said it first
don't get me like a horse and throw me
like a grenade into the Grand Canyon by
the way I just two days ago I had my
wisdom teeth out and yeah I'm doing
wonderfully a lot of you guys have been
sending very very nice concerned tweets
I do have to say it's easy to recover
when you have a wonderful girlfriend
cooking for you non-stop so to get shots
out to the other Jay for making making
me feel so much better I want to give a
shout out to my other Jay for staying
the [ __ ] out of the kitchen the last few
days you know me I stay off the kitchen
it's been so I like Julian I love you
but it's been so nice to have the
kitchen to myself and I can cook things
at my own pace and everything stays
clean all the cupboards are closed the
refrigerator doesn't stay open and then
these meals just appear in front of me
it's kind of that I think I'm like it
wisdom teeth pulled next week to
continuously after that you can just
start started on your molars twelve
years six years start ripping all those
C's and then the front ones have you
seen that picture of Tom Cruise about
how's tooth is like in the middle he's
like a middle to that lines perfectly up
it's one like you know II know it's into
it's just actually is to know it's just
a picture of him Tom Cruise middle no
way yeah it's a yeah no it's it's a
picture it lines part like the middle
teeth lines up with the center of his
face okay so his right front tooth lines
up a center no that is I get it he just
has one front tooth no he does no it's
just one it's right it's right there
that is not an incisor this is one front
tooth no it is there's no - that's one
and then the molars that's all teeth
work okay miss dentists ladies it would
be really funny though if you got all of
like your other front tooth pulled so
you just have one of the neuera braces
so that all the other one what is this
picture you get braces to move all of
your front teeth back so you could
implant a new one middle tooth one
master tooth I'm gonna one-up ya what
you get braces to push all your teeth
back and then you put a whole other set
of teeth like a shark so you get two
sets of teeth no so that when you're
taking a bite of food you hurt the food
a little no pull out all of your teeth
except for one and leave it as a move
one top one bottom that's two teeth we
should stop over ahead all right
but thank you guys for hanging out in
front of the podcast leave us the 4017
commons leave us some good 20:17
comments and tweet us some 20:17
comments on add jana Julian power on
Twitter Oh judge you we get that we
won't judge you
Debbie helps us with that Twitter so
just bombard her with those in those
times please I'm sorry mom
Danny loves it thank you guys see you
later big fan see you next week bye
you
[Music]